wie die geschichte von katze cleo ja die
wirklich wie durch ein wunder überlebt
hat hier sehen wir sie cleo wurde von
einem katzenhasser angeschossen mit
einer schrotflinte und doch hat sie
überlebt und über dieses unglaubliche
happy end meinen wir sprechen ja nämlich
im studio haben wir besuch bekommen
zweifachen besuch bekommen wir stellen
uns erst mal ganz in ruhe vor die
tierärzte sind gabriele marquardt ist zu
uns gekommen und wer dennoch ja das ist
jerry habe ich mitgebracht das ist ein
vier jahre alter kastrierten kater und
super flauschig
ja und jerry schaut sich hier um und ist
ganz interessiert hier in unseren vielen
lichtern und sie zu kommen selbst und
lieblich selbst wirklich wer ist der
kollege da drüben in dem bildschirm wir
sprechen aber über diesen unglaublichen
fallen hier quäler die tiere verletzen
wie oft kommt so etwas überhaupt bei
ihnen in der praxis vor also ich war 34
jahre in berlin hin tätig als
freiberufliche tierärztin und ich muss
sagen ich habe etwas öfter in der praxis
gesehen oft sind das auch zufalls
befunde dass man also das tierchen
röntgt aus irgendeinem grund und stellt
dann fest dass in irgendeinem körperteil
an projekt hier steckt interessant dabei
ist es so dass einige tierhalter das
überhaupt nicht bemerkt haben also in
die sache ich habe gar nichts gemerkt an
den kirchen oder so da ich weiß gar
nicht wann das passiert sein soll
aber also das bedeutet dass es wirklich
auch einige fälle gibt in denen das
offensichtlich gar nicht zu großen
schäden führt aber und ein paar zufall
entdeckt wird aber ich habe auch schwere
fälle gehabt also ich kann mich sehr gut
zum beispiel man einen steckschuss in
der leber erinnernden hab ich das
projektil aus der leber des tieres noch
aus operieren müssen also das sei selten
dass bei cleo waren sehr mehrere schüsse
mehrere projektile mich hat das total
überrascht dass so ein kleines tier das
überhaupt überleben kann also können sie
anhand von jerry einmal zeigen
wo ungefähr auch diese treffer dabei
cleo waren und ja wie eine ganze das
tatsächlich so überleben kann wäre das
also ich denke dass cleo sehr viel glück
hat da einfach deswegen weil vermutlich
nämlich mal an die entfernung zu dem
schrotgewehr doch erheblich war bei
ansonsten hätte das also wirklich zu
heftigeren verletzungen führen mit
meinem menschenbild also ist es wichtig
sein dass wir hier weiße punkte sehen
das sind schrotkugeln organe ja das und
glaube was sie im vorderen bereich
sehen von mir aus gesehen ist es links
da haben sie die den brustkorb sie
erkennen die lunge an der dunkel schwarz
färbung luftreiniger raum stellt sich im
röntgenbild immer schwarz da so darüber
zieht sich lang ich glaube dass auch
hinein ersichtlich die wirbelsäule da
sehen wir vor allen dingen dass gerade
im wirbelsäulenbereich doch eine
erhebliche anzahl von schrot kügelchen
besteht und das natürlich bei näherem
auf treffen hätte das auch erhebliche
schäden im bereich der wirbelsäule
hervorrufen können also das hat bei dem
tier dann auch zu lähmungen führen
können also insofern kann ich so
riesenbeck hat sie in meinem leben die
man auf seiten heißt aber dass jedes
einzelne kügelchen heraus operiert
werden muss oder kann man auch sagen
auch dass eine stadt nicht das löst sich
irgendwann oder würden abtransportiert
ich denke also abtransportiert werden
sie nicht aber sie wären verkapselt das
heißt es bildet sich dann so winden
bindegewebes kapsel darum und der körper
isoliert diesen fremdkörper praktisch
selbst und bei so einer großen anzahl
von schrot kügelchen das wäre wirklich
eine erhebliche chirurgischer aufwand da
jedes einzelne kügelchen aus dem abend
ihr heraus zu operieren so dass das ich
denke das war ja auch die entscheidung
von den kollegen das jetzt erst mal
abzuwarten und zu schauen ob
cleo damit nicht erst mal so klar kommt
und der körper das war der isolieren
sitzt das herz der katzen das licht
ihrem ford und bereich ist sie sehen
hier bei jerry sind vorder beinchen hier
so einen bogen und direkt praktisch hier
in dem in dem bereich sieht man dass
dadurch das herzchen februar cherry das
mitmach erstaunlich dass lang war sie
dann hier das herz hatten den katzen
also vielen dank für die tollen
erklärungen und jahre hand serie neo
werden sie jetzt kurz kennenlernen bei
uns denn wir sprechen mit nicole mirwald
die diese unglaubliche geschichte von
cleo uns erzählt hat uns mitgebracht hat
nicole biewald aus schifferstadt in
rheinland pfalz mit cleo nämlich größte
sie ganz herzlich
ich bin den akkorden gewalt ich komme
aus schifferstadt und da oben sieht man
schon die katze kleben die anschlag sage
ich jetzt mal überlebt hat hier geht sie
zu weit auch ziemlich gut muss ich sagen
da bin ich auch sehr froh drum
nehmen sie uns einmal mit wie sie das
ganze erlebt haben wie das passiert ist
wie sie cleo dann gefunden haben an
diesem tag an dem ihre katze von
mehreren schrotkugeln im körper
getroffen wurde wie haben sie es erlebt
ja also ich kannte diesen kanal schon
zuvor weil zwei wochen vorher wurde mein
vater erschossen und an dem tag habe ich
eben dieses mal wieder gehört und wusste
dann sofort
passiert wieder nichts gutes ich bin
dann auch sofort ins haus gestürmt und
habe nach meinen katzen gesehen und
kleber nicht da dann bin ich natürlich
total in panik rausgerannt und habe sie
überall gesucht weil sie sitzt immer
vorne vom haus und da war sie nicht und
das war natürlich sehr merkwürdig und
dann habe ich sie einfach überlaufen
gelände gesucht in allen straßen
abgelaufenen habe überall in den büschen
nachgesehen ob ich sie finden kann und
nach einer stunde kam sie dann gott sei
dank aus dem nachbarsgarten total
verletzt und humpelt und auch total
zerstört und da war ich natürlich froh
dass ich sie lebendig wieder gefunden
habt
wie ging es dir denn dann sind sie quasi
sofort mit ihr zum tierarzt garant
konnten sie erkennen was da vorgefallen
ist
ja also ich hab sie eingepackt bin mit
ihr in die tierklinik in frankenthal
gefahren und ich wusste natürlich da
waren knallen karte dazu verschossen das
muss wieder das gleiche gewesen sein und
dahingehend habe ich natürlich dann in
der tierklinik auch gesagt dass sie
bitte mal nachsehen sollen ob das nicht
wirklich ein schuss war weil mir wurde
zuerst gesagt sie hat sich
wahrscheinlich mit einer anderen katze
gerauft und dadurch eben diese diese
kunden zugezogen aber wie gesagt mir war
klar dass warnschuss und dann wurde eben
auch eine röntgen bild angefertigt und
da konnte man es ganz klar erkennen dass
es schon partikel sind im körper diese
geschichte bei ihnen hat jetzt ein happy
end zum glück für cleo hat sie sich
verändert durch diesen ja durch diese
schüsse auf sie
ja sie ist natürlich total schreckhaft
also bei lauten geräuschen zuckt sie
zusammen ist immer er so geduckt
unterwegs total vorsichtig und ja er ist
auch im moment nicht so wirklich gut
also man merkt schon dass sie noch
deutliche stress anzeichen hat auf jeden
fall da über ihn im beta sehen wir sehr
auch liegen auf einen katzenbaum der
sitz jetzt vielleicht geht es nochmal
einwenden dass sie jetzt ganz gemütlich
und entspannt aus deswegen freuen wir
uns dass auch wenn sie natürlich noch
von diesem erlebnis sicherlich zu zehren
hat und das zu verdauen hat freuen wir
uns dass das gut gegangen ist für katze
cleo weil sie so gut auf sich auf gute
besserung an katze cleo und vielen
herzlichen dank des yens zu bescheiden
an
lange verweilt hier im studio bei uns
die ärztin frau marquardt mit jerry ganz
kurz zum schluss ihre botschaft an die
katzenhasser im land dies ganz offenbar
gibt ja es ist ein sehr hässlich auf
lebende wesen zu schießen ganz egal
welcher couleur selbst beim kleinen
vogel ist das nicht in ordnung und weil
die tiere leiden dabei sie erleiden
schmerzen sie sind genauso schmerz fähig
wie wir menschen auch und das sollte man
doch vielleicht anders lösen wenn man
sich bei nachbars katze der auf jeden
fall jerry fühlt sich jetzt schon
richtig wollte am liebsten bei uns im
studio behalten aber den nehmen sie
wieder wenn ich danke ihnen sehr
herzlich und auch danke schön an jerry
für den besuch jemals im studio ja gerne
[Musik]